have you ever wondered what the millions
youtubers are making why don't TV show
that the office or Parks and Rec come
onto YouTube for free there's already
plenty of mainstream content from TV
being uploaded onto YouTube from as
creators like the got talent series
America's Got Talent has her own YouTube
channel with 14 point 1 million
subscribers pulling in over 100 million
views per month during seasons same
thing with Britain's Got Talent
and recently Australia's Got Talent
other TV shows like grown Ramsay Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy Kimmel and countless others
have capitalized on this opportunity as
well and what about all the news
platforms CNN Fox News NBC but then why
haven't we seen full fledged TV shows
come on to the platform the first
thought that comes to mind is cost it
probably can't make as much money on
YouTube as I do on the major networks
but this is not necessarily true if this
was the case then how are all these
channels posting on YouTube they will
surely be losing millions of dollars if
it was much less profitable to post on
YouTube on top of that ABC has already
proved this model on their own website
if you go to abc.com you can actually
watch most of their shows for free from
shark tank and a good doctor Turner
shows like stuff down the episodes do
get released a week later and you do
have to sit through commercials but in
the end consider that they have been
doing this for quite a while now it
proved that it is still profitable now
of course posting on YouTube would also
mean sharing profits with YouTube but as
these are large corporations I'm sure
they could cut a deal with YouTube and
also get sponsorships and make it
possible let's take a look at America's
Got Talent again in season 13 they had
16 episodes which averaged 9.5 million
views each totaling to about 152 million
views on YouTube not even full episodes
but single acts are able to garner as
many views as the entire season did on
TV furthermore a single video electives
could generate several hundreds of
thousands of dollars possibly even over
a mil
dollars off of a single act this is
oftentimes how much money full episodes
make on TV and did I mention that this
is simply off of Adsense alone granted
these are happen all the time but this
showcases the money-making potential on
YouTube so hopefully that's enough
evidence to show that a lack of many
shows on YouTube is not because of lack
of revenue potential from the platform
see to understand why TV shows don't
come on to YouTube we have to first
understand how they are funded first
when a TV show idea is created it is
pitched to a TV networks and then if a
TV network agrees to pay for production
and they have certain rights to show
where exclusivity may be part of the
deal and then these TV networks are
pitched to TV providers like dish and
DirecTV who have to pay these networks
to offer these networks and these shows
to their customers so the TV networks
like ABC and NBC not only make money off
of ads in their shows but also from TV
providers paying them in fact they
actually make the majority of their
money around 60% from the providers and
only around 40% from the ads as we just
discussed this entire money could be
made and even more on YouTube but here's
the thing TV providers have been
struggling over the past decade
especially with the rise of Netflix for
instance dish lost nine hundred and
twenty thousand subscribers in just 2018
alone and their stock price is over half
in the past five years and it's pretty
much the same story with other TV
providers as well
DirecTV lost two point three seven seven
million subscribers between q1 or 2017
and q1 of 2019 so clearly they need all
the shows they can get to keep as many
subscribers as possible as a result sure
they must be paying more to networks but
that's not the biggest factor rather the
main factor is that their payments are
less and
viewer based generally TV providers paid
networks a flat fee plus a price for
viewer
however subscribers are leaving in a
hurry these providers are willing to pay
a much higher flat fee to keep networks
with them in fact these fees are trying
to make up the majority of the 60%
income that TV net was get from
providers so sure NBC could go post her
shows on YouTube for free and garner a
much larger audience in these TV
providers dying audience would provide
and potentially make a lot more money as
well but this would rely on their TV
shows actually performing well on the
other hand TV providers are basically
paying these networks to simply stay
with them it doesn't matter how good
their shows are or how many viewers
they're pulling these networks are
getting a guaranteed payment in the TV
industry high funded hype shows often
fill and low funded on popular shows and
blow up it's hard to predict which will
do well and networks notice as well so
instead of letting the revenue be
determined by how popular they are with
the audience they decide to stick with
the TV providers for as long as they can
furthermore shows that have come on to
youtube have high click paid potential
America's Got Talent is able to milk the
YouTube algorithm with highly intriguing
titles and thumbnails their success
isn't dependent on other episodes or
acts
if one act pulled off an unimaginable
feat they just drove tens of millions of
euros onto their channel if another
acting miserably fails they may drive
even more views onto their Channel same
thing with news networks they can simply
put trumpeted blink whether good or bad
and expect millions of views however if
the pilot episode of The Office does bad
on YouTube NBC would be screwed for an
entire season in terms of funding
furthermore this content isn't as
clickbait able other than some michael
scott memes that couldn't go viral most
of your base would be people invested in
the series AGT and news networks don't
need you to be invested in their series
to click on any one of their videos but
ABC and NBC do and that is why full
fledged TV shows aren't available on
YouTube while they could make more money
100 percent of their income will be
based on a performance of their series
and there would be no safety net while
this works great for a certain shows it
isn't the best option for all shows but
considering the growing trends on
YouTube and downward trends with TV
providers is only a matter of time
before networks switch as well they may
not go to YouTube but there's a good
chance they will post on their own
websites with ads at the same time
though with blockbuster films like
Terminator coming to YouTube for free
it's just a matter of time before these
shows also come to YouTube but that is
what I think what do you guys think make
sure to comment that down below also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop the like and subscribe if you'd
like to see more questions just like
this one answered logically but until
then I'm hari na see you guys on the
next one